hey guys I am back playing Samorost 3
for you and I just want to say a quick
thank you to everyone who wrote in the
comments of the last video telling me
that the control panel for the bridge
thing is probably the control panel for
the spaceship because I think you're
right
so we'll go have a look in a bit but
right now I want to see what this
Storybrooke was about that we picked up
the last episode so let's do that yeah
we picked up this little storybook and I
didn't actually read it so let's see
what it's about
ok so we have this weird black thing
that reminds me of bhatta Nick Euler
actually and a giant squid
a giant spree squid that's great wait
what what does it do Oh
it eats planets cool and then there is a
little planet where the hill on the
planet with some people played all the
music things ok so that's one of the
music things that fell from the sky last
episode and I guess they belonged to
these guys is that the man making our
spaceship I think it is I think that's
the man that makes our spaceship oh so
he's like a mechanical genius and he's
making a robot here like a really big
robot and he's got a black ball kind of
like the one in the beginning of this
book and everyone's singing songs to it
and it looks like souls are going into
the ball and then this guy picks it up
and he sniffs it and he's like this is
this is a good black ball and then he
carries it he's looking very evilly back
at the others like I have sniffed this I
have claimed this and it's my ball no
one touch it and then he puts it into
the giant robot skull this makes
complete sense skull robots don't have
skulls puts it into the head and gives
it life it appears and then they don't
know where this massive sword came from
but they gave it a sword oh and then it
flies up into space on its massive
rocket space boot
and cuts the giant squids tentacle off
and slays the space squid and everyone's
really happy and they ride
are they riding the robot yay yeah they
ride the robot to the moon and take off
its little black ball and oh the robots
like dead it doesn't have life anymore
because they took the life away and then
they go what the hell are they doing now
oh no they didn't ride in the robot so
everything else this book doesn't make
much sense but the end up it's a weird
place singing music to some some guy
that doesn't even have a plot in this
story and oh oh they store the black
thing in here and this guy just stays
there and guards it and he's on the
opposite end of the moon
so I'm guessing that's where we're going
let me know if that made sense to you
they didn't make much sense to me but
we'll put it away and we'll carry on the
game okay so we're gonna go and get that
control panel let's go okay so let's see
if this can be used I can't think of
anything else it's got to be this ready
here you go he's taking it
yeah that's gotta be the mechanical guy
from the story so we on the island with
the big tower I don't I don't know I
don't understand that story
hey go there what's up yeah okay so
using that oversized plant
I was wondering how he's gonna fit in it
because that top bit look pretty small
although he's quite small as well
bye sir thanks for making it for me
does he not expect anything in return
okay good deeds I guess
[Music]
off he goes
always giving you his knife back that's
nice that's considerate okay so I guess
we want to go up now so you've already
been down hmm
where do you want to go do you want to
go here I can't go there I've got to
stay within the circle oh can I go with
that let me go on you
we have collided this looks gross but
that's like there's little nits crawling
on it can you see the nits they're gross
[Music]
this doesn't look like a stray piece of
land it looks like an animal it looks
like we're just variety on an animal
okay
what's this okay do we need to turn all
the red things white I guess so I mean
red is usually a bad color where do
people get the ideas for these puzzles
wait there you go
like oh yeah what should we do here we
need to make it a bit difficult I don't
know let's just put a star of faces and
make some of them red and make them have
to change the color it's just so random
there yeah done let's jump through the
whole I guess
[Music]
am i doing
oh that's pretty
do I have a key
am I supposed to have a key
I wonder where the kids
so cool the art style is so pretty okay
let's go and search for like I don't
think there's anything else to do here
no all right let's go
maybe back and look for a key or see if
we can get to that other place now add a
name you go by hairy little mammal thing
here we go right let's go here this does
not look very welcoming it looks like a
massive ball of dirt really but it's
cold we won't judge we'll just go down I
think I'd be a bit scared though maybe
that bit that was orbiting was something
that fell off from this world cuz it
looks the same yeah got the cool music
though dantana what
maybe if I dig this doo-doo-doo-doo
doo-doo-doo-doo oh why is it takes it oh
my god no oh come on this this is
difficult I don't know why do I have
like any glue or anything moving on
that's annoying
look it's another one of those things I
don't know what to call them like moths
or it kind of look like moths I can I
can listen to it I think it's a sleep
snoring okay no one's in
[Music]
keep mashing if they were real and you
could just walk around the woods and
listen to like all the sounds of nature
it'd be so nice it wouldn't sound
anything like that though but still
[Music]
[Music]
saying I think it's saying that if I go
if I go in this hole I'll come out that
hole so I'm guessing I need to get up
there yes is that true
oh hello can I get up talk to you know
go in there sneak into his house uh-huh
okay this place is layout it's very
confusing but it's okay let's see is
that a noose a noose would be a bit out
of place in this game I think oh it's
Polly
okay good I'll go said it's just I don't
really want you to use the noose little
one I don't really want you shoes okay
so let's go back what I think it's done
now is open the entrance to the top
because you saw the steam come out so it
would it would make sense yeah genius
doesn't already take your genius okay
let's let's plug these strings just like
we did be the other one no okay so it's
gonna be
[Music]
well ma
it's so intense it's so pretty
listen to what you have to say mister
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay I'm not too sure what happened
there but I mean it was pretty but I
don't know how it's helped us progress
how's it helped us progress I don't I
don't know
well you awake now can I talk to you hmm
okay thanks
that was fun who is this it looks like a
traffic light
but like weird what what does it do
oh I can listen to it okay
since uh very intense
[Music]
[Music]
okay wait I think I need to remember
this top right mmm kinda top left ish
two more left and then bottom left okay
I think I got this
thank you sir let's can i okay so if I
take its hat off can I do that
I can't move these though it won't let
me
oh I see okay what was this one I think
it was that and then this one was here I
think and this one was here I'm pretty
sure
damn it was it not hmm unless it was
this one I'm so sure is that one okay
let's see what we can do with these
sleeping creatures wake up hello
[Music]
beautiful they like rapping I approve
[Music]
these games are so weird it's great
[Music]
[Music]
you're dancin do I know you are how
could you not wait why did we do this
what was the purpose of this apart from
awesome music I don't understand
something else come out of here like I'm
just thinking it's like whoa what what
happened when I took off its lid ah no
this is gonna take forever a Stuka music
I'm going I'm good it's the opposite way
for the camera huh no okay we still
haven't found a key which I'm guessing
is why we're here we need to find some
sort of key like I don't know what this
place did I'm not too sure what to do
this party that I'm useless I'm useless
I don't know what to do whoa this is
cool
there's some eyes you have here the
neverending story reminds me of that
let's listen to what he has to musically
say
[Music]
[Music]
what what the hell
something just came out of his mouth for
like a brief second popping him
to have to pop them online like before
they come on come on we can pop them or
something gonna happen now
nope honor
once a thief okay he's look up in the
zigzag that work I think that was right
move it
thank you mister a space turtle are they
bats oh I didn't have to expect them to
do that okay oh I get it I can jump on
the non spiky parts right okay
Oh
ah okay now you can tip on that one
this is interesting jump on that one
jump on that one
gentlemen this one
this one uh-oh
cool you well done
[Music]
it's every time you get to a new area
it's like just gets weirder and weirder
like if a monkey it's a monkey hi it's
Anne if he likes us to do with that
puzzle
I don't think he wants us to share his
little hot tub with him okay that's
nothing oh do I need to go back there
and put the lid on that thing so that so
that they're getting hotter or something
okay let's scream to gauges let's do
that
now you better love things back on oh
it's our lever
what oh my god did I have to have it
open and do this I don't understand I
don't know okay guys I think that's it
today I think next time I'm gonna try
and take off the mushroom bit and then
do this again but I'm kind of stumped at
the moment so if you have any ideas of
what I could do next time then do let me
know in the comments I really appreciate
all your help I really hope you enjoying
this game as well give it a like if you
are enjoying it so I know and I'll see
you in the next video have a lovely day
or evening bye